my job right right now I'm nonpartisan
so whether Obama is delivering it or not
I'll leave to others or my my private
thoughts anybody running for president
and anybody who serves as president has
to do a variety of the same thing which
is to call up the very basic traditional
American ideals and use them to make an
argument about our place in the world
and about public policy certainly Obama
has done that a lot and very effectively
in this campaign he places his campaign
in this context of American history and
of American ideals and our quest to live
up to the ideals in a way that all the
greatest presidential speeches have done
from Lincoln to Roosevelt to to Reagan
and that's what you've got to do and now
John McCain is not as proficient a
speaker from a prepared text he has
written books and when he's in the town
meeting he could talk the same way and
make people really understand how the
moment today meets meets the moments
where the country has been courageous in
the past for McCain you know the
challenge is going to be to step up to a
winning
you